mehr geld für die pflegenden die
bundesregierung legt eckpunkte einer
milliardenschweren pflegereform vor zu
wenig beweise nach dem tödlichen
seilbahnunglück in italien sind zwei der
festgenommenen wieder auf freiem fuß und
triumph für chelsea
im champions league finale gewinnt das
team von trainer tuchel gegen manchester
city die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sieber willkommen bei uns an
diesem sonntag und in allen guten abend
sport nachher in der sendung mit norbert
könig menschen die andere pflegen werden
dringend gebraucht in deutschland sie
sollen deutlich besser bezahlt werden
im ringen um eine pflegereform hat sich
die bundesregierung jetzt offenbar auf
einen plan geeinigt dazu gehören
steuerzuschüsse an die
pflegeversicherung in milliarden-höhe
und ein höherer beitragssatz für alle
die keine kinder haben
florian neumann berichtet an versprechen
dass pflegekräfte in deutschland besser
bezahlt werden hat es nicht gemangelt am
erfolg schon zuletzt scheiterte im
frühjahr der versuch einen verbindlichen
tariflohn einzuführen
also wollte die koalition handeln und
scheint auf ihren letzten metern an den
entscheidenden schritt weiter fehlt bloß
noch die einigung auf letzte details der
arbeitsminister gibt sich optimistisch
es notwendig das altenpflegerinnen und
altenpfleger in deutschland besser
bezahlt werden nicht erst seit corinna
visser was für eine wichtige arbeit ist
und dafür muss flächendeckend nach tarif
bezahlt werden
wir sind jetzt zum letzten abstimmung in
der regierung aber ich will dass das vor
der sommerpause gelingt nach einem neuen
gesetzentwurf der auch dem zdf vorliegt
könnten ab september 22 nur noch jene
alten heime und pflegedienste zugelassen
werden die nach einem tarifvertrag
entlohnen nur nach welchem fragt sich
der chef der dienstleistungsgewerkschaft
verdi
im moment ist es so dass jeder
x-beliebige tarifvertrag in einem
bundesland egal von wem der
abgeschlossen wurde
die orientierungsgröße sein kann für die
privaten anbieter auch ein ganz
schlechter tarifvertrag und das führt
dann zu einem ganz schlechten lohnniveau
in dem gesamten bundesland
zur finanzierung soll der beitrag den
kinderlose zur pflegeversicherung zahlen
um einen zehntel prozentpunkt angehoben
werden auf 3,4 prozent des
bruttoeinkommens
außerdem soll der bund eine milliarde
pro jahr aus steuermitteln zu schießen
was die fdp nicht überzeugt das ist
alles kurzfristiges stopfen von löchern
und das macht die ganzen sozialen
sicherungssysteme eben nicht
zukunftssicherer das ist nicht
generationengerecht eine lastminute
pflegereform der koalition wenn auch die
letzten streitfragen geklärt sind könnte
sie am mittwoch vom kabinett beschlossen
und vor der sommerpause vom bundestag
verabschiedet werden
wegen der sinkenden corona zahlen
fordert die wirtschaft ja dass die home
office pflicht früher endet was
finanzminister olaf scholz zurückweist
wir dürfen jetzt nicht leichtsinnig
werden sagt er das virus sei noch nicht
besiegt die jetzige regelung womöglich
home office zu ermöglichen läuft ende
juni aus
die aktuellen corona zahlen für
deutschland haben eine wichtige marke
genommen inzwischen liegen alle
bundesländer unter der inzidenz von 50
das robert koch institut meldet 3852
neue infektionen innerhalb eines tages
und das sind 2862 weniger als
vergangenen sonntag 56 todesfälle kamen
hinzu
die bundesweite sieben tage incidents
sinkt weiter auf jetzt 35,2 bleiben wir
noch beim thema corona und dem möglichen
abrechnungsbetrug in testzentren
nordrhein westfalens gesundheitsminister
karl josef laumann fordert schwarze
schafe aus dem verkehr zu ziehen und
spricht von einer absoluten sauerei wenn
sich einige bereichern wollten
gestritten wird jetzt darüber wer
künftig schärfer kontrollieren soll
anselm stern mit mehr dazu illegal kasse
machen mit der krise mit corona tests
die möglicherweise gar nicht
stattgefunden haben ein vorwurf der
jetzt die justiz beschäftigt es geht um
betrugsverdacht und um die frage warum
betrug so einfach möglich ist der spd
vizekanzler unterwegs im wahlkampf
verspricht aufklärung wir haben sehr
viel geld eingesetzt damit es möglich
ist sich testen zu lassen und deshalb
darf es natürlich erst recht wegen einer
so wichtigen angelegenheit nichts geben
was mit recht und gesetz und mit
ordentlichem umgang mit geld nicht
vereinbar ist
der zuständige bundesgesundheitsminister
lehnt interviews dazu heute ab und wird
weiter attackiert die fdp etwa fordert
einen sonderermittler zu den test
abrechnungen hauptkritikpunkt die test
verordnung aus spahns ministerium sei
schlecht tausende test stellen im land
ohne echte kontrolle
kritik kommt von vielen seiten wir
brauchen einen kontrollmechanismus der
ist ja bisher gar nicht vorgesehen das
war natürlich nicht so richtig schlau
auch wenn es schnell gehen müsste das
heißt bund und länder müssen sich darauf
verständigen wann wo wie welche
kontrollen durchgeführt werden
corona tests seien gerade die lizenz zum
gelddrucken sagt die stiftung
patientenschutz und warnt aber auch vor
falschen testergebnissen in dort wo da
ist die gefahr sehr groß dass die
qualität nicht stimmt und die qualität
solcher tests ist wichtig weil wir
öffnen gerade die krankenhäuser die
altenpflege eine damit endlich wieder
besuche möglich sind für morgen 8 uhr
wurde eine schaltkonferenz der
gesundheitsminister angesetzt heißt es
am nachmittag aus berlin
in brasilien sind zehntausende menschen
im ganzen land auf die straßen gegangen
sie protestierten bis in die nacht gegen
den rechtsgerichteten präsident michail
surabow und forderten dessen
amtsenthebung
die demonstranten machen den laxen
umgang der regierung mit der pandemie
dafür verantwortlich dass es so viele
corona tote gibt
außerdem fordern sie mehr impfungen und
die erhöhung der sozialhilfe eine woche
nach dem seilbahnunglück in norditalien
sind zwei der drei festgenommenen männer
wieder auf freiem fuß
die justiz sieht keine ausreichenden
beweise dass sie mitschuldig sind an dem
was auf der fahrt von streser hoch zur
mutter ohneberg geschah kurz vor der
ankunft dort stürzte die gondel ab wohl
wegen einer manipulierten notbremse nur
einer der 15 passagiere überlebte ein
fünfjähriger junge die region trauert
annette hilsenbeck
ein moment der stille in stresa die
menschen gedenken der opfer die hier vor
einer woche beim seilbahn absturz ums
leben kam
in der kaffeebar neben der unglück
seilbahn ist die betroffenheit auch
jetzt groß das ist ein doppelter schmerz
in erster linie wegen des lebens der
familien dass durch dieses unglück
zerstört
aber auch weil wir die leute kennen die
diese sache verursacht haben sollen
in der nacht wurden die mitarbeiter des
seilbahn betriebes die festgenommen
worden waren nach anhörung aus dem
gefängnis entlassen
der fahrdienstleiter der gespannten
hatte die note grenze der seilbahn
deaktiviert zu haben bleibt den
hausarrest seine beiden chefs wollen von
der manipulation nichts gewusst haben
sie kamen auf freien fuß laut richter
aus mangel an beweisen doch die
ermittlungen gehen weiter
natürlich am anfang wir haben ja schon
eine reihe von untersuchungen geplant
die weitergehen werden der prozess ist
offensichtlich an diesem punkt nicht
beendet vor einer woche war das zugseil
der bahn kurz vor der bergstation
gerissen aus bisher noch ungeklärten
gründen die gondel raste ungebremst
talabwärts normalerweise greifen
notbremsen in so einem fall automatisch
fixieren die kabine
doch wird eine so genannte gabel
eingefügt sind sie blockiert wie in
diesem fall wäre das entschieden hat wer
also die tragödie an der motor ohne
seilbahn zu verantworten hat nach
derzeitigen ermittlungsstand ist das
noch immer nicht geklärt
jetzt mal ein schnitt in der sendung an
diesem sonntag kommen zum sonntag sport
und ich kann mir denken wohl es losgehen
aber nur weil ich verstehe natürlich mit
der königsklasse vier deutsche im
freudentaumel also in der champions
league thomas tuchel darf zum ersten mal
den champions league pokal küssen und
fühlt sich wie im traum der fc chelsea
bezwingt im englischen finale den
premier league meister manchester city
mit der maßgeblichen unterstützung von
timo werner antonio rüdiger und dem
schützen des goldenen tores kallwitz
ein trainer aus krumbach den bayern und
drei deutsche nationalspieler bei
chelsea sind in portugal mittendrin im
triumph den der frühere leverkusener
kreuz in der 42 minute mit seinem tor
des tages sicherstellt
[Applaus]
dort seitdem ich schon sechs bis
stürmischen finale jetzt hier
chelsea trainer thomas tuchel feiert
seinen ersten großen titel nachdem im
vorjahr mit paris verlorenen finale
gegen die bayern
wir haben gestern gefüllt werden es
vorgestern gefühl wir haben es die ganze
zeit ist ja gesagt wir sind der stein im
schuh mantel von von von city 16.000
fans hatten in porto die partie im
stadion verfolgen können
eine super serie ausgebaut die frauen
des vfl wolfsburg gewinnen in köln zum
siebten mal nacheinander den dfb pokal
durch das 1 0 gegen eintracht frankfurt
nach torlosen 90 minuten fällt die
entscheidung
zwei minuten vor schluss der
verlängerung durch eva prior obwohl die
wolfsburgerinnen nach platzverweis für
torhüterin schult ihnen 18 waren
insgesamt ist es sogar der neunte
pokaltriumph die wölfinnen der erste fc
köln hat sich am tag nach dem bundesliga
klassenerhalt von sport geschäftsführer
horst heldt getrennt sein vertrag lief
noch bis 2023 und zehnkampf-weltmeister
niclas kohl ist mit platz fünf in götzis
solide in die olympia saison gestartet
wichtigste erkenntnis der operierte arm
hält bester im speerwurf 71 meter 49
insgesamt 8200 63 punkte und damit auch
bester deutschland herausragend dabei
der kanadier damien warner der um fünf
punkte an der magischen 9000er marke
vorbei schrammt aktuell top favorit für
die spiele im total fertig da genau was
dann hätte ich jetzt hier noch das
wetter für sie morgen scheint fast
überall die sonne können uns jetzt auf
gleich angucken genau
nur im osten und südosten ist es auch
mal wolkig das ganze bei temperaturen
zwischen 17 und 24 grad und auch an den
kommenden tagen scheint oft die sonne es
gibt aber ein bisschen mehr schauer und
gewitter so zwischendrin
das war es von uns im heute journal
spricht der kollege claus kleber mit der
oppositionsführerin in belarus svetlana
die canucks kaya und er sagt ich
erinnere mich gerade an kein interview
das mich mehr beeindruckt hätte als
jetzt dass mit dieser mutigen klugen
frau 21 uhr 45
wir begleiten sie auch in die kommende
woche ab morgen bis dann wenn sie mögen
aber erst ihnen allen einen sehr
angenehmen abend zb mit jack und alabama
georgia konnte